ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata [ __ ] ciao
ragazzi ben tornati alla nuova puntata
di vita buttata il tema della puntata di
oggi è ex tutti ne abbiamo uno da cesare
e cleopatra brit lei e justin dylan e
brenda rossana eric me è breve e busco
scusate forse non avrei dovuto dirlo
comunque torniamo a noi
esiste un posto fatto di cambi campi
sterminati duringer se non nascono
vengono coltivati
esiste un posto meraviglioso dove gli ex
tornano a restituire tutta l'aria che ci
hanno rubato dove gli ex possono essere
piantati una volta per tutte la uil gut
forest dieci tipi di fusti in limited
edition che potranno permettere di
sradicare una volta per tutte le radici
che sti stronzi hanno piantato nella tua
vita
san valentino è alle porte vivilo anche
tu con un accollo in meno cacao avocado
passion fruit mar caramia mangrovia
banano caffè grevillea anacardio e
macadamia ognuno di loro detentori di un
ricordo un emozione
un gesto che attende solo la pala di
treedom per essere tumulato per sempre
la wilmut forest e un posto sicuro dove
i nostri ex potranno tenersi compagnia e
per quanto assurdo fare del bene al
nostro pianeta in un luogo circoscritto
dove per la prima volta nella loro
esistenza potranno finalmente provare il
brivido di cosa voglia dire crescere
sono 100 i fusti pronti essere piantati
si avete capito benissimo cento un terzo
degli spartani nove volte meno otto i
segni dello zodiaco gli anni esatti di
la partigiana tutto questo grazie agli
amici di treedom che questo 14 febbraio
vogliono salvarci dai soliti fiori e
cioccolatini quest'anno aiutaci anche tu
a dare un utilità a chi un'utilità non
l'ha mai avuto nel dubbio aiuta chi ami
a piantare un ex che la puntata sugli ex
abbia inizio tra di voi si nascondono
100 persone pronte a vincere la libertà
il resto può comunque acquistarlo
facilmente sul sito di trito e proprio
per questo la deciso di invitare
all'interno degli studios the casa mia
una vera esperta di questo tema mia
cugina lavinia fare posso dire una cosa
che il look elegante posso dire una cosa
le coste repen dosarlo ed un like se vi
piaccio così dire a questo punto però di
partire subito in iii liceo che
frequentava con un ragazzo più grande
questa cosa invece da sentire molto [ __ ]
perché spesso mi veniva a prendere con
la macchina seno che un giorno lui era
un grande patito di dottor house viene a
prendere a scuola vestito come dottor
house munito di bastone zoppicanti e
dicendomi che quel giorno non era venuto
con la macchina perché siccome aveva
deciso di zoppicare non poteva guidare
ragazzi questo è qui da internare da
domani mattina e spider man il giorno
tesoro usa ha portato reato di stato a
casa sua dalla scuola cioè per quanti
chilometri ha spiegato questa mattina da
para medico ti lasciava del sole per
mesi per andare a giocare a poche mon in
giro per l'europa crede che vinceva alla
fine acchiappato epica cioè che appunto
uno spirito che abbiamo tutte quante le
persone che hanno condiviso con noi le
storie che state ascoltando riceveranno
uno degli alberi limited edition all
interno della uil but for her swing
forest che ha già piantato un mio ex
ferrosi quindi sarà il primo della sua
stirpe detto ciò avremo il piacere
diventare anche alcuni dei vostri ex a
quelli che sono i commenti più
divertente o comunque più devastanti per
quanto mi riguarda dedicheremo un album
io nè tare chiedendoti hollywoodiani
a raccontare uno ha avuto una crisi
mistica improvvisa mi ha lasciato per
cercare dio ho scoperto la vocazione di
porno attore non ho capito di essere gay
l'ultimo invece è nato in carcere non ci
credo torno crisi mistica dalai lama
carcerati tutto insieme 23 insegnami
rete becchini intera sezione io voglio
già padre pio padre pino vogliamo bene a
conoscenza che questa ragazza è
follemente innamorati di me anche se non
mi ha mai visto per curiosità le iniziò
a frequentare dopo una settimana
vedo che la vostra netta quindi decidono
subito di chiudere apporti e lei mi
mando messaggio dicendomi di stare
attento di guardarmi alle spalle che
prima o poi si sarebbe presa la sua
vendetta ogni portella credevo per la
mia città praticamente lei inseguiva
samara un ragazzo credeva di vedere gli
spiriti e ricordo che ogni volta che
andava a casa sua guiderà volte fissava
il vuoto e mi diceva che ci stava un
uomo una donna e di uso di me mi
scriveva stavo praticamente tutte le
notti sveglio un saluto magari buster
poi come gli hai detto sono basita chi
voglia mollare vino una figura presenza
li seguirò le io ho avuto una
frequentazione con una persona che
cercava la sua anima gemella persa nel
tempo un incantesimo dischiuso 30 e del
tempo suo amore storico che lui ha
sempre visto in sogno nelle sue vite
passate un certo punto era diventato
mozart e stavo cercando di capire se io
fossi mozart oppure loro occhio e croce
direi di no però chi fa dirla
di telecamere e dico dove rimane seria
io sono stato fidanzato cinque anni con
un ragazzo estremamente mammone in
pratica voleva più di scrittura madre
qualcosa che non ho mai fatto e in più
se la madre non doveste oggi non si
vestivano usciva di casa infatti perso
motivo non siamo andate al battesimo di
mio nipote di un'azienda da battisti di
tudin poté perché mammina non è andato a
vestirlo ma tu hai capito che lui voleva
che dormisse insieme alla mamma
pensavo di essere una professionista in
materia di bambini ma in realtà proprio
all'acqua di rosa e questa cosa locali
facciamo un esperimento sociale mettete
like
se avete avuto a che fare con mammoni
ragazzi ci prendiamo un monte di pausa
una boccata d'aria con il segmento se
pronto alla fine a giocare con noi
maicon di preferiresti essere lasciata
per una donna più intelligente o più
bella più bella che intelligente e meno
l'esistenza intelligente non esistono
milano 3 ago che guascone preferireste
essere lasciata dall'uomo più bello
della terra o dalle più ricco della
terra dalle più bello della terra e
ricco per ottengo fa jason mi ama trump
non può vero cuore non mi lasciare ben
ai preferiresti uccidere tutti i tuoi ex
o far vincere ad ognuno di loro un
milione di euro non viene più ne sbatte
e il sacrificio di una vergogna per il
giusto sbattano sai che ti voglio bene
ma purtroppo mi trovo costretto a
sacrificarsi capisci che l'alternativa a
fare vincere un milione di euro a quei
quattro peracottari vero non scherziamo
sbatte ti voglio bene piangerà sulla tua
tomba ogni giorno finiresti una sola
notte di passione con matteo salvini
cedendo a tutte le sue richieste più
perverse di indicibili può essere per
sempre melania trump questa fa tu sei
pazzo per quanto gli abbia profonde
difficoltà nelle tollerare la figura di
don hall penso che sceglierei melania e
matera 26 aprile verona tutele più
fulgide stelle del firmamento
preferiresti non praticare all'amore per
un anno intero oppure farlo ogni giorno
senza mai poter raggiungere l'après midi
all'ascesi per un anno
non ho idea un papà rimanere amica con
qualcuno che amico sposare qualcuno che
ho di sposare qualcuno che odio e
pensare a come ucciderlo sono il rischio
sposare preferireste avere una pagina
nella tua scelta una scelta tra due
gambe perdonami ma se li metto alla
stella tra le gambe la patria dove c'è
alla pagina nella scena sarebbe un'altra
pagina cioè che la mia vagina venisse
proprio spostata sotto la tua scelta
oppure avere una scena tra le gambe alla
mattina sotto l'ascella dai preferiresti
passare tutta la vita indossando solo
ballerina è bellissimo oppure indossando
solamente un paio di calli che la natura
che ha già dato il 12 centri ballerine
mai no no no alla taglia preferireste
essere la moglie di jason momoa ma
rasati a zero per stare con lui e non
poter indossare nessun tipo di parrucca
oppure l'amante di jason momoa ma ad
ogni rapporto doverti vestire da
hercules e abusare attivamente del suo
corpo con una cintura fallica in casa ma
voglio anche abusare di lui voglia tutta
cosa non si fa per estremo individuo ti
vorrei vedere ti faccio una domanda di
mira su a 0 si porta a casa il segmento
sei pronta per riprendere ad ascoltare i
nostri messaggi possa togliere queste
cuffie sono potenziali all blacks
oltre a essere vabbè è uno stronzo
praticamente aveva la fissa dei capelli
noi se stavamo facendo sesso intuiva di
aver i capelli in disordine si alzava e
si andava guardare allo specchio e ti
rimane con la interdetta mihai trovavano
iconiche alcune cose della mia persona
che io dicevo devo dire all'orecchio
come gli piaceva prenderti dietro il
collo con i gatti io voglio ringraziare
questo canale per la tutela della
privacy è fatta è presente tipo quando
prendo quasi non a caso il grido allo
scopo scatola va erogativa evidentemente
ma io ho beccato uno
voleva che facessi camere per un periodo
negativo
il mio primo ragazzo si sono i veri
delle ascelle fermati e credo di non
aver capito il mio primo ragazzo si fuma
i veri delle ascelle
si no i peli delle ascelle hai capito la
mia se fa proprio per non aver capito la
tua stessa proteico me ve li pone rischi
venderei i miei periti sotto le ascelle
a quel punto farei un trito fino come
col prezzemolo e utilizzandolo tipo
tabacco c riempire un hacker in mezzo al
tabacco però attivato mastro peluria
l'esperienza quella che mi manda in
orbita molto figure un rugbista che
veramente mi sto ragazzo agli occhi dei
miei genitori non era molto simpatico
quindi io continuavo cerchie nascosto
fino anche lui non mi dice sta più
insieme
non ci fermerà nessuno teheran sua
fidanzata che praticamente nord in corso
con un sacco di patate il corredo il
supermercato però avuto tu mi dici come
riesce a fare una voce così diversa
dalla tua amica mia cara io ti scrivo
adesso in privato perché vorrei capire
te lo stesso perché a me è capitata la
stessa identica cosa non è una
specialità solamente dei rugbisti tizio
mozart pensavate fosse single mentre
faceva dark turno venditori 33ma mitri
doriani aspettando di riuscire ad
arrivare all mazzarri rugby non è vero
non siete così guasconi siete favolosi
era il mio compleanno
uscivo con questo ragazzo già da un bel
po viene a prendermi al lavoro andiamo a
cena
andiamo a ballare io vado in bagno torna
dal bagno e vedo che si stava mangiando
letteralmente un altro ragazzo e morire
dopo un anno ci sentiamo per gli auguri
di capodanno e tutto quello che lui sa
rispondermi e potresti smetterla di dire
in giro che siamo ex sta gente
ciao ospite vi presento due casi umani
d'eccellenza 1 una sorella che si
scambiava delle e mail con dio in
inglese oltretutto e di naturalmente che
rispondeva e l'altro un rex che dopo
quasi due anni insieme mentre siamo in
vacanza con la mia responsabile un mio
collega confessa che gli alieni
l'avevano rapito più volte la linea io
penso di avere avuto a volte delle
sfighe io ho a volte penso che siamo
stati spiegati alcuni miei ex minacciato
perché non è che so un santo e gia
perche palo veramente ragazzi a un
frassino super il scolaretti rispetto a
quello che ci hanno portato io vado a
dormire sereni quando pensi che la tua
vita ma merda chiedi a qualcun altro
come va la sua ed è per questo la linea
che io ti ringrazio per aver condiviso
con lui la tua saggezza ringrazio
freedom per aver collaborato e
continuare a collaborare con noi fate
una cosa bellissima in maniera
intelligente e divertente fateci sapere
quali sono le esperienze con i vostri ex
riera che la possibilità di piantarne
uno all'interno della wii u boot forest
metteteci un like se avete avuto a che
fare con un mammone ma soprattutto
attivata la campagna le notifiche per
non perdervi nessun appuntamento con noi
ci vediamo domenica con la puntata di
cucina buttata ciao ciao